Tony you just told me something really
interesting as we were hanging out in
the green room which is that from pitch
to release this movie was only two years
time that shocked me because I always
think of animated movies as taking I
don't know twice that was that always
the plan and how were you able to do
that so quickly well first I it's such
an honor to be here thank you for having
us in this amazing building I guess I'm
taking the academies but it's just so
such an honor to be here so um you know
we when Michelle and I pitched it to the
studio it was two years ago and a few
places wanted a few places were
interested and we ended up going with
Sony Tom Rothman really believed in it
and said but the thing is I want you to
make it in a year and we were like we
that's insane he's like okay - but no
more so so because technology changes so
quickly we didn't know if emojis would
totally change in two years so we had to
make it fast and it was very challenging
but thanks to the hard work of all those
amazing artists that you just saw we
were able to do it
Michelle how did you feel confident you
could do it in two years as a producer
you know what you don't know you don't
know I I had been in an executive and
animation for a while running the
production division of Sony and I knew
the head of production there and and I
knew the Imageworks team at Sony and I
felt like if anybody could do it we
could do it I knew would be tight but
yeah what was the real fun part I would
imagine a group of you writers story
people producers directors must have
gathered in over some kind of
brainstorming room to think of all of
the fun that you could have maybe
scrolling through your phone looking at
all the different emojis thinking like
oh this we could do something really fun
with this what was the beginning process
like as you were trying to figure out
which emojis you would bring to the
forefront in which you would even drop
in for a gag here and there it really
started in the script phase with Erich
Segal my co-writer and with Michele
before we pitched it to the studio we
really worked on it and we brainstormed
in and we knew which kind of apps we
were starting to think about and what
care we had the main basis and then when
we got to the
studio and you get such great people
like Mark and Dave and the rest of the
team then you have more brainstorming
and it just takes it to the next level
and it really you get some of the best
artists from around the world some of
the best thinkers just figuring out that
those emojis how do you make it look
like on your phone so like we just we
just we thought like Hollywood Squares
so they sit in the Hollywood Squares
waiting waiting to be a star and know
that we had to design the hand that
scans them so there was a lot of
brainstorming between story and art when
you think back to all the lead roles was
there one that was the hardest to find
the perfect person for finding the
character of smiler was really hard
so with Maya we really Michelle my and I
had a lot of sessions in the booth where
we were trying different voices and
she's so versatile which means there's a
lot of choices so we would find and what
we ended up with was that smiler is like
the head of the cheer squad and she
wants her squad to win first place in
the you know and so she bet she really
wanted to do anything it's a yeah yeah
so that's that Amaya landed on that yeah
were you guys all super excited and
surprised to see how the whole idea of
Sir Patrick Stewart has poop just took
off into this extent where I think
that's the one thing that most people
know about this movie whether they've
seen in or out they're like oh yeah
Patrick Stewart's poop I mean it was the
Joker was intended to be the joke we
went to him he got the joke immediately
you know he never put Sir Patrick
Stewart on a credit he got the joke and
it's the joke he wanted to put Sir
Patrick Stewart as Sir Patrick shirt as
Pope yeah makes it elegant yeah
Dave a lot of your work I would say the
vast majority of your work has been on
non animated movies whether it's Harry
Potter you know so many different things
that you've done for decades how is your
job different if at all for a movie like
this given that it's animating yeah I
come from a visual effects background
but so we're used to little chaos so I
hopefully you know with with the
production theatre that we had I was
able to bring a lot to that we have a
amazing animation team that works on
both visual effects and animation up to
350 artists touch this movie I think one
of the things that we want to do here
was
you know make the characters very iconic
but give them a very sophisticated look
and so all the characters and all the
objects in the movie and we had so many
different environments to explore and do
that with but they all had a really
interesting quality of how the light
kind of came through them so they all
had a little bit of transfer of light so
make them kind of feel like they were
still attached to the light in your
phone the light that projects from a
phone mark can you talk a little bit
about how you guys I think it was
important for you all to strike a
balance between the technological world
and the real emotional world that this
movie also lives in and not to kind of
tilt the balance one way or the other
but have both of those come through was
that something that you work
specifically on yeah we wanted to make
sure that whatever obviously our main
character was Jean but he all the emojis
and everyone in that phone were
servicing a user Alex and it was really
important to whatever when things are
normal and then in the phone the world
of the phone or when things get chaotic
what does it how does it affect the
outside users world and what would that
user do it was really important to just
see the both worlds and how they like
progress throughout the movie and how
would we solve the problem to fix that
and I have the solution yeah and also I
don't I didn't get a sense at the end of
the movie that you guys were
particularly like pro always being on
your phone or anti always being on your
phone the movie kind of sits in the in a
middle ground there and understanding
what they can do but also understanding
the detriment as well right that's right
we we you want to take that one yeah we
worked very hard to make sure that that
balance that we didn't have a at first
we thought we should make up we should
make a statement about technology and
then we thought it becomes too political
it's much better to tell stories in
metaphor and allegory which is what we
tried to do so that's how we we decided
to well guys thank you so much for
joining us today it's great to meet all
of you